souvent on arrive on dit salut man ça va
dans le packaging le marketing week-end
nike et ea email si shakespeare
finira-t-il par avoir la peau de molière
l'anglais s'est fait une place de choix
dans la langue française ses sables
franglais et ça dure depuis plus d'un
siècle la culture américaine se propage
l'économie se mondialise les modes
s'exporte et avec elle les mots un mal
oui pour certains linguistes des
écrivains dont rené etiemble dans les
années 60
si je suis quelquefois si enfin comme on
dit réjouit presque agressif
à ce propos là c'est que je suis très
touché c'est que je suis très inquiet je
crois en effet qu'une civilisation ne
survit pas si elle abandonne ce langage
en 1975 la loi s'empare du sujet et
interdit les termes étrangers dans les
factures les notices d'utilisation
les inscriptions dans les services
publics et les contrats de travail mais
de la sanctionner les contrevenants
à défaut de moyens d'application dont je
ne vois pas la mort nulle part dans la
loi ni dans les débats la loi sera ou il
appliqua mais non appliquée ou appliquée
d'une façon peut être arbitraire en 1994
la loi va plus loin l'idée de traduire
les mots anglais nouveau d'interdire les
mots étrangers s'ils ne sont pas
traduits notamment en entreprise dans la
publicité et les médias
des sanctions sont prévues cette fois il
ya une loi qui m'interdit de dire des
mots que se passe-t-il retrait des
subventions éventuelles
je suis sur scène publique déjà on paye
pas intervention des officiers de police
judiciaire j'ai carrément lakers qui
vont venir à la sortie pour maintenant
alors et pour marquer la page que j'ai
dit
glenn berger je reconnais que là en
effet c'est un point sur lequel sa
droite
oui absolument fou absolument fâché
fâché mais choux vaches et fashion et le
numérique accélère l'anglicisation de la
langue
l'académie française tente de lutter
avec un concours lancé en 2010 par
exemple pour franciser des termes
nouveaux roissy quelques exemples chat
préféré et blabla ou le tchatche buzz
ramdam tuning en français deviendrait
bolidage voilà qui n'est pas gagné mais
rappelons le jusqu'au xviiie siècle
c'est le français qui a envahi le monde
il en reste encore quelques marques à
l'étranger un baiser restaurant rendez
vous tout un programme
[Musique]